so welcome to Gras tour Jeffrey it's not
your first tournament in Gras tour that
you are participating you were here last
year uh do you think somehow it helps
you the fact that you have played it
already and you feel more confident this
year oh for sure because it's very
intimidating playing with these guys so
to get that experience makes it um more
comfortable and I think this is my third
time so hopefully third time is the
charm yeah you just actually come in
from Grand Swiss tournament which was in
N men and um how can you assess your
participation there how was the
tournament for you it was a very nice uh
venue but unfortunately my play was not
so nice um but it's still a very good
experience what did go
wrong uh I think at the beginning I made
a few too many draws and then started to
become a bit
frustrating um and then sort of took too
many risks later on um are you a
professional chess player right I mean
in these days and um can you tell us a
little bit how the life of the
professional chess player looks like
what is your routine what are you doing
every day how many hours per day do you
prepare for the games yeah so I think on
on average it's about 4 to 6 hours for
me uh that's how much I work and for
this event I mainly did some general
preparation so got some some of the
openings that I plan to play in order
and some middle games end games as well
yeah but in general mean you wake up and
you start starting chess immediately or
let's say what what is the best schedule
you can have as a professional player uh
do you work with a coach uh no coach at
the moment but yeah okay I guess I wake
up and usually I do some physical
exercise first in the morning just to
wake up a bit and then then I get into
some chest and it's sort of um you know
work on chess take a break and maybe eat
something then exercise some more and
then go back to chess yeah uh what are
your other interest interests Hobbies
I'm a big sports fan so I play a lot of
sports I watch a lot of sports what are
your short terms and the long-term goals
um in your chess career uh shortterm
probably returning to 2700 would be my
first step um right now I dropped quite
a bit so just to get back on track there
and long term I think we'll see right
now I'm just
playing uh to enjoy and hopefully if I
can climb the ranks that' be nice yeah
and uh actually I noticed in the video
you sent us before the chess tournament
I've noticed uh lots of books on the
background I I was wondering if you have
read all of them or some of them and
what what is your favorite yeah I can't
say that's that was my uh room I was
actually filming it uh in my parents
room so my dad is a very big reader I
also have a big bookshelf but I don't
read quite as many books I would say um
one of my favorite books that I read
though is the is a classic uh animal
farm so this is one of my favorites um
um who are some of your chess idols and
uh how they influenced your chess career
and your approach to the game um I have
a lot of Chess Idols I think an
underrated one for me like one that
doesn't get um said enough I think is
Vladimir karnick I really eny enjoyed
his his games um when I was just before
grandmas I studied a lot of games and
that catapulted me from let's say 2450
to
2650 so I would definitely mention him
as one of the players that uh made an
impact yeah you also you are so lucky to
work personally with Gary casparo the
world champion you attended this school
for young talents and uh in St Louis
Club it was also organized here um so
what was uh
this unique experience you had um you
know working with Gary yeah it was truly
amazing just to get a chance to um be
around him in person and yeah we worked
many years I think maybe six or seven
years together um I could show him my
games and he would comment on them yeah
it was really really nice and I think a
lot of players benefited greatly from
that experience thank you so much and
all the best of luck for you in the
tournament thank
you